hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today's
question comes from one of my newsletter
readers runny who wrote in asking about
helping to grow his business so I love
your story I'm a young entrepreneur and
I'm trying to market and finance my
business I sell building materials and
soon I'm starting consumer products
please help so thanks for the question
Ronnie a challenge a lot of
entrepreneurs face how do I you know
grow my business get more companies and
more customers coming in to buy what I'm
selling in your case I would think the
main thing for you is trying to build
around your customers so I don't know
how many your clients you already have
but I would focus on the the customers
who you can add meaningful tangible
results to who also have a budget so
build around their problems build around
their pain points and I would focus on
the business customer so you mentioned
you sell building materials and you're
going to launch a consumer product line
consumer products are really really
tough it's not that it's not possible
it's just really hard it's expensive to
launch expense at the market and every
time you're selling your selling
one-offs so it's really hard to get the
cash flow coming in so a lot of
companies get blood dried because
they're there you know blowing their
brains out trying to you know create
that marketing engine this held the
consumer market i would first if you're
having financing issues and marketing
issues i would first focus on the
business market so if you already
selling the business clients for your
building materials focus on them more
what more can you do to help them
business customers are great because
they'll do repeat orders if you're if
you can become a vital part of their
business they're going to want to make
you a part of their business right
they're going to want to keep ordering
from you on an ongoing basis as they
need more in your case materials but
whatever you're selling they're going to
need more of it ideal it's a consumable
that they can use on a you know keep
ordering on a regular basis from you
that's great they also make bigger
orders so if you are talking to business
owners hopefully some bigger companies
they're going to order a lot more
quantity than the consumer market will
on an individual basis so you might have
a bigger overall opportunity going
to consumer market but it's again
expensive and really risky to go after
when they make an older it's one order
to order it's really small where if you
go to business you might sell one
hundred a thousand ten thousand right
it's a lot easier to make the bigger
quantities and to bring in the cash
again when you're starting the business
and you're at the brink of you know
failure because you run out of money you
got to get cash flow coming in and
that's easier to get from business
market than from the consumer market so
you can get you know bigger orders
coming in and awesome way to build a
business if you can so I would focus on
the built the building material business
and not so much to consumer market until
you're able to get to the point where
you're supporting yourself right you may
have you know big dreams of what you
want to sell is an awesome consumer
product marketing idea if you in the
future but I you know put that on hold
keep that in mind definitely but get
your business to the point where you're
able to survive support yourself you
have some cash flow coming in from your
business clients that then you can
afford to spend a little time energy
resources money to build this consumer
side of the business for the business
side my favorite strategy to get in is
start on a small order so make it really
you know friendly towards them small
order test you out almost risk free for
them and then over deliver like crazy so
you're going in you're providing crazy
amount of value you're giving them
training you're giving the support
whatever you can think of to give them
amazing service beyond anything that
your competitors are going to do because
that that sets you up so that first
trial you coming in on you may not be
making a lot of money you may not be
making any money maybe a break-even
maybe even be a small loss for you but
you're getting in the door to prove
yourself this is your chance this is
your trial and it's a great way to get
into these big companies because you
know what they're going to be wanting to
buy more from you ideally if the night
is an ideal target market target
business where they have you know big
orders that they could potentially give
you start small get in there make it
easy and then over deliver like crazy so
you're providing awesome service
whatever you can think of to really
stand out in their mind training support
going in walking through how to use your
product even things not related to you
know
your business whatever you can think of
again to stand out because when it comes
time to reorder if they've had an
amazing experience with you and okay
experience with the guys are already
buying from then they're going to give
you more business and give them less
business right most of these guys are
probably already dealing with a supplier
so you have to displace the existing
supplier so you do that ideally not on
price because that's a hard way to make
a business but you do it on the service
and if you can provide amazing service
and stand out the business customers
will want to make repeat orders from you
bigger quantities and hopefully tell
their business colleagues about you as
well so hopefully that helps if you guys
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below I love seeing those coming that
makes me want to do more of these videos
for you guys and if you have a thought
to add to this video or we have a
question for me I only read the comments
below so I really appreciate if you want
to leave a comment underneath so thank
you and you'll see you on the next
episode
you
you